foreign
breaking news tonight a new escalation
in the fight between Congress and the
FBI over a document that purportedly now
accuses your President Joe Biden of
participating in a criminal bribery
scheme that he took specific action in
exchange for money for his family as
vice president now the house oversight
committee chairman James Comer says he
is now prepared to hold the bureau the
FBI Bureau that is in contempt of
congress if they do not return or turn
over that document now we asked the FBI
for their side of the story they
actually responded and they told us that
they remain quote committed to
cooperating with congress's oversight
requests on the matter well then hand it
over all right to that end Fox News has
learned tonight that the chairman
chairman Comer and FBI director Ray they
are set to meet in coming days and
meanwhile Hunter Biden's tax Affairs
they are still being reviewed although
it is unclear if there will ever be a
resolution now that IRS whistleblower
who accused the feds of giving Hunter
special treatment is now speaking out
for the very first time take a look at
this there was multiple steps that were
were slow walked at the direction of of
the Department of Justice had you ever
encountered that before I have not no
these deviations from normal process and
each and every time it seemed to to
always benefit the subject don't want to
do any of this I took oath of office and
when I saw the egregiousness of some of
these things
it no longer became a choice for me it's
not something that I want to do it's
something that I feel like I have to do
all right here at the very latest he is
the house oversight committee chairman
James Comer is back with us sir welcome
back
thank you all right
so you and your committee are prepared
now to hold director Ray in contempt but
now we're hearing that you will be
meeting with director Ray
um at issue is this 1023 form that an
FBI whistleblower made you aware of that
talks about specific actions Joe Biden
may have taken in exchange for money
that's exactly right I sent director Ray
the letter threatening contempt of
congress proceedings if he didn't hand
over the document at three o'clock just
a few hours prior to coming on your show
Sean I received word that the FBI
director is committed to meet with me
next week in Washington and we can
discuss this but nothing's going to
change with respect to holding him in
contempt of congress if he doesn't turn
over the document not only do I expect
the document Sean I expect to know
exactly what the FBI did to investigate
the validity of the claim because if I
as I've said on your show before this
claim is consistent with activity that
we have seen in other countries around
the world and it all stemmed over the
course of 2015 and 2016 during the the
end of the Obama Administration when Joe
Biden was vice president and he took it
upon himself to travel all over the
world to to some of our adversaries
around the world and talk about foreign
policy and foreign aid so but a 1023 is
a confidential informant that would give
information that they would take it
maybe it's not fully corroborated now
the question is did they do a full
investigation A and B and secondly if
they feel or fear that this may be made
public I'm sure you would agree to see
it in a skiff or a private setting would
that be fair
that would be fair but it's not
classified so the their argument that
says they don't want to out there inform
it I agree with that 100 there's a
process in Washington to to prevent that
and that's called redacting the name of
the informant that solves that if the
informants claim isn't legitimate then
again why are they worried about the
informant look we learned something
during the the second conversation we
had with people representing the FBA
when they came in to talk to my staff we
our specific request first of all said
we want any form 1023 dated in August
2020 with the word Biden on it and you
know what they came back and said Sean
they said well that's that would just be
too many documents uh we we can't
possibly prepare all that so you know a
light bulb goes off what do you mean how
many 10 23s are there with the word
Biden just for one month in 22 20. now
this is what we found with the treasury
with the suspicious activity reports
there were hundreds of these indicating
potential wrongdoing of the binds with
respect to financial transactions now
the way that I understood the FBI there
are multiple form 10 23s pertaining to
Biden so we had to narrow the focus to
say okay Biden and the word five million
dollars all right so let me let me ask
you this do you have evidence that the
FBI may have more may have more than one
confidential human Source in the summer
of 2020 alleging a Biden bribery scheme
and what do you know about Hunter Biden
wooing Chinese Executives with
high-level CCP ties while fundraising
for a movie Venture with with bulger's
nephew
well with respect to China more and more
comes out every day we've already had
one press conference where we proved
that Joe Biden was not honest with the
American people during the presidential
campaign when he said his family never
took money from China we we've proven
that and I believe there are many more
transactions that that will be able to
present to the American people but with
respect to the FBI they could have had
many meetings with this informant but
the way the FBI described it in the way
that that my staff and I interpreted it
was there were multiple 10 23 so it
could have been the same in four
multiple I met with multiple times but
do you have multiple sources is what I'm
asking it could be multiple sources or
it could be one uh
you know again the the name of the uh of
the informant is is
confidential right okay all right uh
anyway James Comer thanks for the update
we appreciate it keep up the good work
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else